what is happening there reject nation
greg and john here today we are going to
watch a clip i'm assuming is a fight
scene from shang chi in the legend of
the 10 rings it's called scaffolding
escape figured this is our last
opportunity to react to a clip where he
could feel
genuine i know some other reactors who
sometimes watch movies early in advance
and then they still do reactions it's
not our style can't do it name name i
will not name
several people
we're going to watch this because we're
supposed to go to the shank chief mayor
knight i'm actually going to pick up
cosmic wonder in just a couple hours
from now from the airport in the
meantime let's get to it
[Music]
[Music]
oh
cool
yes
yes
oh
i've got a lot of thoughts i loved it
loved it so much it immediately brings
me back to like a jackie chan fight
scene of using like the props around you
like i love the moment when he steps on
the plank and then it flips up and hits
the other guy or uses the one guy as a
bridge using uh the environment around
you as a as a weaponry um it feels like
a really good fight because this is just
a tease your mind there's just like 30
seconds of one fight scene so you gotta
imagine what the whole movie might feel
like and we're gonna get such a wide
variety of fights we'll get the
tournament matches we'll get the final
fight between the mandarin and chongqi
but for this group fight a lot of the
time
that i think can go wrong with american
cinema fight scenes is it feels like
people are kind of just attacking one at
a time and especially with your marvel
lead they could almost feel invincible
and what i loved about this because i'm
assuming this is rather early on in the
movie the shanghai is having difficulty
he's not super powerful heroic to the
point where he seems indestructible or
invincible or you can't let a hit on him
like there's plenty of times where he's
training blows with the ninjas he's
actually fighting with and it does
really have like a jackie chan s
choreography to it i think like for
american audiences the the rush hour two
fight scene with the scaffold team might
be one of the first things that comes to
mind those are my favorite kind of
action heroes like i feel like jet li
bruce lee often wouldn't get hit in a
fight like this
but actors like jackie chan would
actually get blows landed on them and i
thought this captured it very well so
i'm like this is just one fight just a
little tease i feel like a lot more
assured that this could be easily the
best fight scenes in any of the mcu
movies that's what i'm hoping for yeah i
mean this you know if you go by the
previous trailer's context these are you
know the mandarins you know task force
or there that his you know team to go do
stuff like this and so i feel like you
kind of have to make it a closer fight
you know something to really at least
justify you know the menace of you know
the forces that the manor has at his
disposal but also then show you seong
chi's potential moving forward that
whole thing about told them they
wouldn't be able to kill you i'm glad
that i was right and uh yeah just
looking at the cinematography too like
there are a lot of ways to approach a
fight scene and this appears to be very
kinetic but also still fluid and clear
enough that you can tell what's going on
and hopefully appreciate all the
choreography it doesn't seem like it's
too much cutting but at the same time
the visual language has a lot of energy
and you can tell that there is a lot put
into the camera motions to enhance you
know those moments that are a little
more jackie chan like and that do borrow
from the silent movies even that he was
you know inspired by too so not to say
like this is going to be
fully that but i feel like yeah all
those kind of things are at play here in
a way that makes the action especially
seem super exciting beyond just like oh
cool whiz bang you know well i believe
andy from marshall club uh the pretty
much the lead of marshall club you guys
haven't seen that channel it's fantastic
stuff i know he's one of the characters
in here i i don't remember which
character it is and i'm not sure if his
character's in this fight scene but i
know he's involved with the choreography
of it his biggest influence and biggest
inspiration is jackie chan so seeing the
inspiration take place here is just even
more evident and that wasn't actually i
was expecting more of like and i'm sure
there'll be a variety of different kinds
of fighting scenes but this is more
grounded level where shang qi is just a
regular civilian which looks like san
francisco still i feel like they're in
san francisco probably yeah i'm not sure
i don't know where they're at especially
if he has to like buy time for aquafina
i would imagine that they're probably
still somewhat close to home you know
before they leave and go you know for
the full adventure some people were
thinking that they might be a major poor
at one point in this movie and there's
something about like that skyfall neon
lighting that's kind of making you think
about that yeah
but my point being is that i think why
some of the the stuff might look a tad
bit off in this fight scene is because
they are still dealing with cgi they are
still dealing with visual effects can't
go full jackie chan to the point where
you're like let's just bring a crane up
here and only shoot there yeah they have
to be this extra safe and then with
certain maneuvers you can tell some of
the ninjas are cgi and there's things in
the background that are cgi but for the
most part it still feels mainly
practical and grounded for what we're
getting one of the most unrealistic
parts of the fight because shanghai i
don't know if it's going to be in the
movie i thought it would be i thought
the director said it would be but maybe
i'm unsure but he's not exactly only
human because that's one of the main
appeals about him is that he's a master
martial artist the best martial artist
in all marvel but he's not only human to
the point where he can't do some
supernatural stuff like in the comics he
has this like cloning ability that he
can do i don't really know about
enhanced super strength there's the one
part where the weapon shocks him yeah
and like i feel like in if this was a
real life fight obviously
that would have that would
i'm gonna follow you and have some kind
of adverse reactions sure for the most
part it looks great and also uh you know
i want to get a better taste of what the
score is before i'm like solid score but
i'm hoping that the the musical score
in this movie is because i i like the
way it sounded here i don't really have
much thoughts on it but you know the
marvel movies sometimes have incredible
score and sometimes bland score we'll
have to see but so for the most part the
score sounding pretty good that's pretty
good enhance the action all right guys
well shaun chain the legend of the ten
rings did you get your tickets already i
heard they went on sale today leave your
thoughts down below what do you think
about this clip subscribe click that
notification bell hit that like button
last but not least
fox this was a kick-ass clip and if
there's anybody at our patreon who could
easily jump into a fight and kick an ass
i think that it's you in fact i want you
to train me i'm not very tough and i'm
not very buff and so i think that you
could get me whipped into shape to the
point where maybe just maybe i could
hold my own if attacked by an elite
force of weapons carrying martial
artists that's right fox you know a lot
about fitness but you know we could take
it to the next level all right we could
become the heroes for hire this world
deserves you and me all right so uh hit
me up return any of my messages i don't
know why you're still pledged and yet
you're still ghosting me about this but
uh we got some settles to score scores
to settle you know what i'm trying to
say fox
in seriousness really appreciate you
been missing your comments lately but
very much happy that you're still part
of our patreon and hopefully we will
talk again soon
be well
and all the love
[Music]
you